au milieu de l'océan indien si beyrouth
l'une des îles les plus sauvages
d'indonésie une jungle tropicale coupé
du monde avec pour unique août lors de
ses longues robes
la seule présence humaine ici c'est une
tribu que l'on appelle les mentawai
ils vivent comme des hommes
préhistoriques
loin du monde moderne
recchi contraint et anthropologue depuis
cinq ans ici à lille pour étudier cette
tribu indigène l'une des dernières au
monde
d'ici quelques années je pense qu'ils
vont disparaître c'est pour cela que je
viens ici c'est peut-être ma dernière
chance de pouvoir comprendre leur mode
de vie
rares sont ceux qui s'aventurent dans
l'archipel l'univers de ces aborigènes
et sauvage
et dangereux
une jungle dont il faut se méfier pas
seulement de sa végétation vénéneuse ou
de ces insectes mortels mais surtout les
esprits qui l'habitent
[Musique]
l esprit du singe
te manger nous
écoute moi je t'appelle
leur joie nous laisse moi te chasser
esprit de la jungle soit clément avec
nous protège genoux et de thé danger
enfin nous une bonne chasse
qui est né dans cette jungle et
plusieurs fois elle a failli le tuer
avec son petit-fils l'oubli et okapi ils
chassent leur viande préférée
le macaque
est haut
je pense qu'il ya quelque chose là
pourquoi les je n'arrive pas à savoir si
c'est un singe toc qui reste convaincu
d'être le meilleur chasseur duclos même
s'il n'y voit plus grand chose
je ne peux pas l'atteindre je ne le vois
plus mais ne vous moquez pas de moi
c'est quand même moi le meilleur
vous voyez le poison et l'a conduit sur
un point
quand elle touche l'animal le poison se
libère
pas besoin d'en utiliser plusieurs une
seule suffit même pour me tuer moi
rencontre seul et c'est la mort
après plusieurs heures de marche
toujours pas de singe pourtant ils ne
vont pas rentrer les mains vides
[Musique]
un cochon sauvage est tombé dans l'aude
leur piège
[Musique]
bon c'est vrai on n'a pas eu de singe
mais celui là on l'a eu c'est mieux que
rien
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
est-ce que nous couchons
on ne tue pas pour rien
tu vas nous nourrir ne soit pas fâché
je t'offre ses feuilles pour que tu
retrouves la joie au paradis
cookie est intimiste pour lui même le
cochon est un homme sur lequel il faut
veiller
une fois tu es ces ossements feront
partie de la famille
on respecte tous les animaux c'est pour
cela que l'on garde leurs craintes si on
ne prend pas soin de l'esprit du cochon
se retournera contre nous et la jungle
aussi et du coup son esprit ne nous
donnera plus jamais de proie quand on
ira chasser
chez les mentawai il n'y a pas de
village le clan vie dans une ou ma une
grande maison communautaire
celle de coûts qui regroupe quatre
générations
elle s'appelle melda c'est ma petite
fille elle pleure tout le temps
[Musique]
oh
la femme de l'hoggy a accouché de leur
troisième enfant ici même sans eau sans
électricité
de leur quotidien les mentawai partage
tout enfin presque tous
[Musique]
chez nous on ne peut pas dormir avec sa
femme c'est interdit c'est tabou
les hommes restent entre eux et c'est
pareil pour les femmes
nous on dort dans la partie droite de
l'oumma et les femmes à gauche c'est
comme ça
pas le temps à venir mais comment vous
faites l'amour alors
si on veut faire l'amour on le fait
ailleurs dans ce qu'on appelle la maison
des poulets
parce qu'on dit aux enfants que l'on va
nourrir les poules est tous les couples
mariés en ont une
mais elle est ailleurs
il n'y a pas de chef de la tribu chez
les mentawai le pouvoir appartient à
tous
[Musique]
attends papa moi aussi j'en veux
pour certains la vision que son mais
utopique
c'est juste le moyen le plus sûr de
réussir leur vie
partagée c'est notre force c'est le seul
but de notre vie
on a tous besoin des autres pour nous
montrer comment faire quand on ne sait
pas
on se dit tous nos problèmes
et on trouve des solutions ensemble
et c'est parce que l'on partage
de notre vie sera longue
si l'on surnomme cette tribu les hommes
fleurs c'est pour elle l'hibiscus
symbole de leur harmonie avec la nature
leur ancêtre la porte et déjà
depuis des millénaires cette jungle les
a coupés du monde des mentawaï serait
moins d'un millier disséminés sur cette
île presque aussi grande que la corse
cette fleur c'est un symbole pour nous
les chamans
quand on s'apprête à faire quelque chose
de spécial on met une fleur d'hibiscus
et cette feuille le moon n comme ça
notre âme c'est qu'une cérémonie se
prépare
lui s'était gogo le plus vaillant de la
tribu selon les anciens
nous sommes invités à le suivre car
aujourd'hui il va vivre l'une des
journées les plus importantes de sa vie
de mentawai va se parer d'un nouveau
tatouage
sur pas dtn ça c'est une grange de coco
jeu l'arabe pour en extraire l'eau pour
fabriquer lancre
et pour pigments de la cendre la recette
est inchangé depuis des siècles tout
comme l'instrument
ses légumes en métal il faut que je les
guide pour la nettoyer
petit coup sec lugi fait pénétrer
l'antre dans la chair tout le clan s'est
réunie autour de tes gogo pour le
soutenir
[Musique]
moi je me rappelle encore de la douleur
j'avais mal dans tout mon corps
celui là il fait extrêmement mal je m'en
souviens moi j'ai eu mal partout j'ai
même pleuré c'était affreux parce que
sur les autres c'est très douloureux
j'ai beaucoup pleuré
sit & go go continue de se tatouer c'est
parce qu'il veut séduire son âme pour qu
elle ne le quitte jamais son quoi dit-il
il pourrait mourir
mais les femmes notamment la sienne ont
une explication bien plus pragmatique
vous savez il on a deux tatouages plus
on est belle et crise on n'est belle que
nos maris nous aiment et du coup il ne
se fâche pas contre nous et il nous
quitte jamais
les mentawai aurait été l'un des
premiers peuples indigènes au monde à se
tatouer
[Musique]
mais ces tatouages tout comme leurs
croyances les ont condamnés à des
décennies de répression
une période sombre de leur histoire
c'est celle qui intéresse ricky
l'anthropologue il a enfin rejoint la
tribu
oh
[Musique]
qu'est-ce que vous prenez la et les
corses pour faire quoi notre pagne
dans les années 50 des missionnaires
catholiques sont arrivés sur l'île et
des du gouvernement ils convertissent de
force les mentawai parce qu'ils étaient
considérés comme des sorciers il les
oblige à quitter la jungle
coûts qui avait tout juste 20 ans
il était contre votre culture c'est ça
il n'acceptait pas vos pratiques comme
le tatouage notre pagne en écosse nos
dents aiguisées nota tous âges j'ai été
puni pour ça
et les cheveux longs tout ça interdit et
qu'est ce qu'ils t'ont fait
ou non mis en prison à la deux semaines
ils m'ont gardé là bas et puis ils se
sont servis de moi comme un esclave ils
m'ont fait porter du bois
et c'est pas tout on fait creuser pour
construire leur maison c'était ma
punition
jusqu'en 1980 les mentawai sont
sédentarisés de force dans des villages
le long des côtes pendant des années
cookie est au cap qui se sont cachés
dans la jungle pour continuer d'être
chaman
les autres ont dû renoncer à leurs
croyances
et dans ces villages du gouvernement ils
continuent de pratiquer votre culture
d'être animiste
non c'est fini
ils ont tout perdu
il y en a plus un seul qui vit comme un
rêve mentawai
portent des habits ils travaillent dans
les magasins ils sont catholiques ou
musulmans maintenant
la culture mais
maintenant ils nous laissent faire nos
rituels et vivre ici mal acquises à
c'est parce qu'ils y trouvent leur
intérêt des touristes viennent nous voir
pour sa
100e ils ne nous auraient jamais laissé
rhône mais pour l'argent le gouvernement
est prêt à être à la baule à dany et
vélo à main
[Rires]
[Musique]
mais il est déjà trop tard
les enfants de la tribu sont la dernière
génération à vivre dans la jungle comme
leurs ancêtres
l'école ils n'y ont jamais mis les pieds
mais préfère jouer aux aventuriers avec
du bambou ils fabriquent leurs propres
jouets et les oiseaux qu'ils capturent
sont leurs meilleurs amis
une enfance sauvage au coeur de la
jungle et tout ce qu'elle leur offre
saas et les verts de l'arbre c'est pour
mon frère
des verts bien juteux en guise de goûter
leurs friandises préférées
c'est délicieux
[Musique]
je les préfère quand ils sont vivants
tu veux essayer
ils savent bien qu'une autre vie est
possible
loin de leur île mais ce choix ils le
feront plus tard
si un jour je vais à l'école j'ai répété
de chercher un travail en ville mais ce
qui est sûr c'est que je reviendrai ici
peut-être que je ferai des allers
retours entre là bas ici je ne sais pas
encore
al oumma la tribu est inquiète
ricky l'anthropologue est tombé malade
une violente fièvre l'empêchent de
travailler
l'hôpital est à plus de 10 heures de
pirogue
alors tu okapi t go go et coûts qui vont
le soigner ce sont des sikhs et rei les
guérisseurs de leur communauté
[Musique]
ça c'est de la sica lotois le jus et ça
soigne les poumons
c'est exactement ce qu'il nous faut pour
le malade rappelle que c'était
ta caméra qui touchent pas
parce qu'ils sont chaman ces guérisseurs
sont vénérés par leur clan
le seul détiennent les secrets des
plantes le seul moyen de se soigner dans
cette jungle
ce sont les ancêtres qui ont appris ces
gestes
il faut être très précis
des gogos est aujourd'hui le dernier
guérisseur de sa génération
le seul médecin pour sa tribu mais c'est
justement ça qui le préoccupe
si nous disparaissons sans transmettre
nos secrets on ne sait pas qui va guérir
qui va protéger ces arbres
pour que les plantes fast effet il faut
attendre la tombée de la nuit
[Musique]
les chamans entame un voyage mystique
ils vont communiquer avec les esprits
pour la première fois et qui va être
soigné selon les rites chamaniques
un remède purificateur dont on enduit sa
peau
ils n'ont pas le choix ici le seul moyen
qu'ils ont pour se soigner ses les
chamans
quelques heures plus tard la fièvre de
riz qui est tombé mais pour éviter la
rechute les chamans doivent respecter
une règle ils n'ont pas le droit de
toucher leurs femmes pendant quatre
jours
l'un d'entre nous fait cette erreur
c'est très grave ils seront tous en
danger l'esprit de la plante peut nous
tuer
[Musique]
ces rituels chamaniques tout comme la
pêche traditionnelle des hommes fleurs
deviennent peu à peu une attraction pour
touristes
voilà il est là le poisson je cherchais
enfin j'en ai un
plusieurs fois par an la tribu accueil
des visiteurs comme nous
à leurs risques et périls
je leur dit de faire attention il ya des
serpents dans cette rivière il m'a mordu
plusieurs fois
vous trouvez aussi des araignées
venimeuses quand vous mettez vos mains
là dedans
le passage de ces touristes ne leur
rapportent presque rien du sucre
quelques habits
m'attribue les aime bien mais ne
comprend pas vraiment quel est le sens
de leur vie
et dans les îles vous devez payer pour
tout ce que vous faites pour manger pour
vos vêtements il est toujours question
d'argent naba nous on est heureux on n'a
pas à se demander si on a de l'argent ou
pas
[Musique]
moi
quel sera l'avenir de cookies et des
hommes fleurs sol il de si beyrouth
difficile à dire
aujourd'hui le gouvernement encourage le
développement d'un tourisme ethnologique
une ouverture au monde qui pourrait bien
faire disparaître leurs cultures
à moins que les esprits de la nature et
ses fleurs d'hibiscus n'en décide
autrement
non
en
[Musique]